que vous lisez on lit tous on a aussi
des enfants des petits enfants
ça tombe bien figurez-vous que typhaine
failli faire vient régulièrement et en
2019 aussi vient pas nous faire
découvrir des sélections livre avec vous
on a parlé de vaccins ce matin c'est
totalement le hasard mais prendre soin
de sa santé ça commence souvent par
l'éducation des enfants avec de la
lecture et des livres que vous nous avez
emmené ce matin typhaine oui pascal et
vous savez quand on est tout petit son
corps ça reste très mystérieux
d'ailleurs au tout début on ne sait même
pas qu'on ait une personne différente de
sa mère et je vais vous dire comme
disent certains médecins je me tourne
vers fort sur archos qui est là hop là
je fais une petite pirouette dans ce
sens là ton corps change c'est ça que
vous dites aux enfants aux petites
filles et petits garçons
tout est normal sur nous et commence pas
connaître son corps bien joué très bien
et bien pour les tout-petits j'ai ce
livre là ça s'appelle le corps mon
imagier animer ces publié chez gallimard
jeunesse
et alors c'est absolument idéal pour les
petits à partir de 2 ans puisque il y a
des petits volets à ouvrir jeune homme
voilà pour découvrir bien les yeux les
mains les bras et surtout à quoi ils
servent
parce que quand même le principal c'est
de savoir à quoi servent aux différents
organes ce que vous pouvez en faire
voilà et puis c'est très bien à partir
de deux ans trois ans et puis ce livre
il apporte autre chose c'est qu'on dit
déjà aux enfants dès 2 ans et bien
prenez soin de vous on va le montrer hop
là nourrissez-vous leveaux si tiger mais
allait aux toilettes ça a l'air bête
mais ça commence dès tout petit bon cd
volés qui sont pas électriques ou
électroniques car je précise je précise
pour la smit proteor qui sont lassés des
volumes annulations sont expérimentés
même quand on est d'accord pour les plus
grands à partir de 6 7 ans c'est
carrément une plongée dans un autre
univers que vous nous proposez dans le
corps humain avec deux ouvrages qui sont
assez différents
louis allard celui-ci s'appelle
professeur astro cat voyage au coeur du
corps humain c'est de dominique allimann
et ben human je vous le montre c'est un
vrai coup de car ça vous rappellera
sûrement il était une fois la vie
ah oui j'adorerais ça qui fait le ton la
qui passait sur france 3 bis évidemment
alors regardez ça une équipe
d'astronautes plonge au coeur du corps
humain alors on vous emmène partout vous
emmène dans les neurones on vous emmène
au coeur des ce cas là et on vous emmène
parmi les muscles et on vous explique
tout alors c'est très riche en
illustrations alors à la fois des
grandes illustrations et puis de
l'infiniment petit et on vous explique
de manière assez imagée et bien que le
corse et cent mille milliards de
cellules ou bien un neurone réagi aussi
vite qu un karatéka alors se répandait
dans sa défense de lure à la quête mais
ça dépend
merci ça dépend de l'heure à laquelle
nos neurones sont sollicités n'est ce
pas
les petits mais ils réagissent comme si
vive pascal sont de meilleure qualité
voilà elles sont bien donc c'est à lire
est absolument idéal à partir de 6 ans
jusqu'à jusqu'au collège et même pour
les adultes
ça répond à toutes les questions pour
les parents pour les enfants vraiment
c'est à avoir dans votre bibliothèque
c'est vraiment encyclopédique et puis il
ya pas mal de page
voilà c'est vraiment je vous le
conseille vous m'avez dit de livres ça
veut dire qu'ils ont à un autre et bah
oui parce que si vous lisez ce livre
vous allez avoir envie de jouer au
shérif joe j'étais petit je joue au
docteur x ce sera aussi pour les
médecins avaient perdu peut-être la main
de secondes 10.2 le taf en sueur cost
dans les facs de médecine toujours un
nouveau scan est ou pas
pas à ma connaissance non parce que je
me rappelle en a fait une émission
spéciale à la fac de besançon et le
squelette porter un nom pour les
étudiants je crois que c'était un
couteau je pensais qu'il voulait venir
partout je suis moche cette génération
ça me rappelle quelque chose moi j'avais
en easy de rente est isidore damian quoi
ça rime
l'un celui ci vous pouvez laver comme
vous voulez pascal thomas avec ce petit
fascicule qui me donne quelques
informations efforts là pourquoi si vous
pose quelques questions vous pourrez eh
bien on va dire explorer le corps humain
en l'opérant carrément puisque le
squelette se démonte complètement je
demande comme vous avez les petites
pinces pascal je vous laisse faire et
lui enlever à l'intestin mal à le croire
lorsque vous voulez voilà après galeao
l'intestin s'enlève a le x sans lait
voilà vous pouvez tout enlever ça fait
par les autres le sont également et
constituer un corps humain doit comme
donc c'est pour ceux qui préfèrent
mettre les mains dans le cambouis et
expérimenté par eux mêmes tu peux aller
on va terminer avec un dernier ouvrage
crois que c'est un roman c'est ça oui
parce que là on a parlé de documentaires
et donc je vous emmène dans le monde du
roman avec l'auto girl de georgia bling
c'est publie aussi chez casterman
et cette fois c'est une plongée dans un
futur un petit peu inquiétant ou la
génétique décide de tout c'est un peu
une sorte de bienvenue à gattaca
si vous avez un patrimoine génétique
idéal eh bien vous aurez un bon travail
une bonne éducation et tout ce qui
s'ensuit est dans ce livre est bien on
tire au sort quatre jeunes filles et on
leur dit bon même si vous n'êtes pas
parfaite vous allez avoir l'éducation
rêver et et bien on verra si vous y
arrivez donc ce livre c'est cette
histoire est ce que ces quatre jeunes
filles vont réussir à suivre le cursus
scolaire est ce qu'elle vous réussi à
relever le défi
ça parle de perfectionnement de
sélection génétique de résistance aussi
car tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
avec ce monde là vous vous en doutez et
de puissance des multinationales tout en
proposant à partir de 12 ans je vous le
conseille
quatre ouvrages à découvrir avec ce
petit jeu aussi à voir ou à revoir sur
france tv point fr et sur la plateforme
de france 3 et sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que typhaine fait les choses bien
et chaque fois nous mais tout ça en
référence et c'est plutôt sympa j'adore
votre squelette moi j'ai un coup de
coeur pour le scanner
à 8 h si j'osais je dirais même taquiné
notre médecin voiliers mais je vais pas
le faire je vais pas le faire mais je
mets j'oserais enfin papa faut tout
remettre en place
comment vous dites pour mettre les
organes mais justement avec les plans de
montage justement tiens je vais vous
laisser tout remettre en place pendant